johannes ist schon da ist der immer
immer ist der immer die Vorhut hallo
vorch den schicken der muss immer die
Lage checken ja sehr gut okay da sind
wir ja auch schon bei unserer ersten
Frage so sch ja das ist hier zack
zack geh schie los wie ist die Lage die
Lage ist gut wir sind alle total
erfrischt hatten alle ein paar Tage frei
nur diese Frau nicht also die Lage war
ja die Lage war mal schief aber da wir
eine Wasserwaage haben haben wir die
Lage wieder in eine eine richtige gute
Lage hinbekommen okay danke für den
Beitrag
Wie kommt also wieso wenn man Single
veröffentlicht hat man da wirklich
vorher Zeit kann man sich einfach
muss man da nicht tierisch was vorher
machen oder sonst was also es kommt
drauf an wir haben jetzt mit der Single
wirklich viel Vorlauf gehabt und haben
das Video schon dazu schon vor ein paar
Wochen gedreht und allerlei auf die Bahn
gebracht und jetzt hatten wir
Revolverheld Teil eine Woche Urlaub und
Martha war auf Tour mit ihrer eigenen
Band ja ich war auf Tour durch die
deutschen österreichischen und
schweizerischen Lande und hab eine
Stimmbandentzündung da dazu gehabt ist
aber heute sehe ich diese fremden Jungs
sozusagen und sie haben mir irgendwie
wieder Leben in mein Leben gehaucht ja
danön genau weil du darf ich das so
sagen tanzt auf vielen Hochzeiten du
hast was Hochzeiten sind so schön man
kann umsonst Essen umsonst trinken man
findet immer jemand der mit ihm ins
Hotel in der Nacht geht Hochzeiten sind
toll nur die Frage wie ist dann der
Kontakt zu
revol ja also ich kenne die Jungs von
revol schon total lange komm jetzt
erzählen wir kennen uns wirklich sehr
sehr sehr lange und 5 Jahre ist das her
waren die Happy bei der Band und
Revolver hält zusammen auf Tour da habe
ich zwar erstmal mein Bild da war die
Lage sehr schief ja die Lage war echt
ich glaube das war so die zweite Tour
also seit dem ihr veröffentlicht hab
damals das Album und mit die Jungs und
meine drei Jungs zusammen oh Gott das
war eine absolute Katastrophe
diabolische Kombination ja jede viel
Kopfschmerzen Abend ja wir waren ganz
gut feiern und waren viel unterwegs und
Matha hatte auch da stimmbadentzündung
ne hatte killkopfentzündung
killkopfentzündung und wir haben ja wir
haben Support gespielt hab nur vorne weg
25 Minuten kurz Krach gemacht und dann
haben wir schon angefangen wenn die
Jungs von der Bühne kamen dann ging es
los und das war wirklich die wildeste
und härteste Tour des ganzen Lebens aber
es hat uns alle samt für immer
zusammengeschweißt okay ja und eben aus
dieser Erinnerung haben dann die Jungs
plötzlich johannes hat angefangen mich
schonich SMS zu schreiben wo ich dann
dachte oh vielleicht findet er mich
jetzt doch irgendwie süß und so und
konnte das nicht vergessen und auf dem
alten Rad lernt man besser fahren ne
weil ich halt älter bin und so schöner
Satz und dann und dies ein altes Schiffs
können ich nicht vorstellen und dann
habe ich mir gedacht was will der denn
und kann ich dich anrufen kann ich dich
anrufen ob er meine schöne Stimme hören
will oder so habe ich angerufen und er
hat mir zwar Komplimente gegeben aber er
all ja du bist halt die Sängerin an die
wir als erstes dachten er hat natürlich
sehr diplomatisch gesagt als erstes
dachten die hat nich auch andere im Kopf
aber ich war wohl weiß nicht wie vi
gesagt du warst die schönste glaube ich
ja ich bin so versaut ich habe heute so
gute Ideen aber das kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen W hättet ihr lieber eine
Sängerin ah man muss sagen das ist schon
gar nicht so schlecht deswegen freuen
wir uns jetzt auch auf die auf die ganze
Zeit die jetzt kommt mal so mal so eine
Frau vorne da stehen zu haben das ist
auch schon nicht schlecht was fürs Auge
weißt du genau h ich hab nämlich viele
viele viele hübsche Freundinen in jeder
Stadt und deswegen ist es besser eine
Sängerin zu haben weil den Sänger will
jeden und deswegen ist es für die
anderen Jungs der Band immer ein
bisschen traurig weil sie keine
abkriegen weil der Sänger sie alle
abkriegt bei einer Sängerin ist es
anders ich bringe meine Freundinnen
immer deswegen sind schöne Parys und die
jüngst sind nicht auf mich alifersüchtig
weil ich auf Männer stehe und genau muss
auch sagen die Jungs von der happy sind
so ver zweif das ist eine einzige Chance
also siehst wahrscheinlich haben wir
eine sehr sehr gute Zeit vor uns ja okay
das ist natürlich toll aber ist das
wirklich so dass er alle abkreg und ihr
da
immer am schau am Fenster steht und
zugucken
müsst m wir müssen auch immer zugucken
wir werden gezwungen ist schon echt
traurig also wir haben alle schon Knacks
mitbekommen und mal sehen aber
Therapeuten und so weiter gibt's ja wie
Sand am Meer insofern wir haben serel
Glck ser Schlagzeuger der nimmt einfach
immer alle mit auf Hotelzimmer und das
ist das ist halt echt das ist echt gut
das wissen die meisten Fans dann jetzt
auch schon und Jakob macht da eigentlich
keine Gefangenen das kann man auch ruhig
in Öffentlichkeit mal sagen also wer
Lust hat Jakob sing immer allzeit bereit
woran liegt das jetzt muss Jakob das mal
erklären was
hast was hast du was die and nicht haben
die ich habe keine Freundin
das so einfach ist das ne und dann na ja
mehr sage ich nicht okay okay also die
ander ihr habt alle Freundinen under
dürft ihr das nicht sagen habt ihr im
Vertrag stehen hier oh Gott die Frage ne
nein wir sind alle vergeben wir haben
sogar teilweise Ehefrauen hier der her
ist schon verheiratet der hat das alles
schon hinter sich und
er hat ein
bananenglied und ja das deswegen ist
Jakob
der Jakob sucht eine Freundin ja ja auf
der unser Schlagzeuger sucht auch Jürgen
sucht auch eine Freundin aber man muss
dazu sagen dass Jürgen auf eine andere
Art und Weise
sucht egal okay der muss alles erstmal
austesten können wir ganz kurz Kön
vielleicht kurz ein Aufruf machen Jakob
ja bitte in die Kamera Jakob schon genug
gesagt ein hübscher Mann ein
erfolgreicher talentierter Musiker so
ein
Herz sucht ein nettes Mädchen die für
ihn Kochen wird die auf ihn zu Hause
warten wird
ungefähr so gebaut ist wie ich
und die gut knutschen kann und die ihn
nicht nur wegen seines Geldes will danke
schön Ende der Durchsage nee aber mal
noch mal ernsthaft gefragtin got okay
jetzt erthaw nein du willst will was
ganz anderes wissenen und W ich will
wissen ob es nicht total schwierig ist
wenn man so im Rampenlicht steht eine
Freundin zu finden weil man ist immer
auf Tour oder man ist abends danach ist
man besoffen morgens ist man noch nicht
wach man ist ja eigentlich immer in
ungünstigen Situationen oder gehe ich da
vollkommen fehl in der Annahme mit
rampenlichicht musst eigentlich auch
mattha Fragen oder wieso mit Rampenlicht
na ich meine du bist mehr im Rampenlicht
als wir und wie ist das für dich für
mich ist es toll ich meine es ist
einfach also es ist nie
einfach es ist nie einfach jemanden zu
finden was heißt das ist nie einfach es
passiert es passiert nicht und da ich
z.B noch nie ein gruppi
hatte ich Schw schwö
schwör wenn man jemand findet und man
dem erklärt und ich habe einen
erwachsenen Mann und der weiß das wie
das geht natürlich ist der manmal
traurig dass ich nicht zu Hause bin aber
deswegen macht man so Kamikaze geile
geile Sachen wie ich fliege gerade über
Frankfurt irgendwo hin du bist da lass
uns kurz in Frankfurt am Flughafen
treffen ehrlich solche
Sachen also ich kann nicht die
Überschrift über dieses Interview
schreiben Beziehungskiller Popmusiker
nee aber wir können jetzt auch ein
bisschen über Musik reden wieder oder w
auf jeden Fall
toll okay toll reden wir über Musik halt
dich an mir fest also ich wenn ich jetzt
Spinner höre und halte ich an mir
fest für mich sind das fast schon Songs
von zwei Bands also anders oder würdet
ihr das nicht sehen nee überhaupt nicht
also ich glaube es ist auch kein
Geheimnis dass wir immer eine Band waren
die jetzt nie ganz straight nur in eine
Richtung geschrieben haben sondern das
ist aber einfach immer sehr vielseitig
bei uns und ich glaube das mögen unsere
Fans auch die kommen auf dem Konzert und
hören sich gerne Rocksongs an aber dann
auch gerne mal eine Ballade dazwischen
und wir haben auch öfter so Akustik
Blocks im Set wo wir dann so die akusti
die wandergitarren auspacken und dann
Nummern wie mit die chillen spielen z.B
mit chillen hat ja dann auch wieder mit
den beiden Nummern vielleicht auch in
deinen Augen nichts gemein aber trotzdem
ist es ja ein revolverhsong und ich
glaube die Facetten sind auch gerade das
was uns ausmacht ja das ist das so ist
auch Rockmusik finde ich ich meine ich
muss ich wundere mich manchmal wenn ich
von der Bühne runterschaue und wir
spielen live eigentlich kaum Balladen
und rocken rocken rocken und da ist ein
weiß nicht ein 30jähriger voll
tätowierter vollbertiger Typ da der
ständig da steht und macht den immer mit
uns und plötzlich kommt eine Ballade und
das Publikum macht den und er macht's
auch und hat Tränen in den Augen ich
meine auch die die härtesten Rocker
haben ein Herz und Balladen sind einfach
das wo plözlich Erinnerungen wieeder
wieder hochkommen und das Balladen
gehören zu jeder Band sogar die die
größte Death Metal Band hat eine Ballade
sei es nur
textlich lieb ich bin so traurig so
wohin geht dann in Anführungszeichen in
Zukunft die Reise jetzt bei uns allen
hier ja also natürlich sind wir jetzt
erstmal mit Hal ich fest gut unterwegs
mal gucken sing kommt am 5.11 raus und
die Happy haben jetzt gerade die Tour
schon fast hinter sich ihr habt noch ein
paar Dates ne wir spielen Dezember noch
zwei Wochen Deutschland weit da können
wir drüber wir spielen nämlich den
ganzen
Dezember s ein bisschen jünger noch wir
haben schon fast 1000 Konzerte auf
unserem Buckel ja wir
haben ja okay wie viel wir haben 600
glaube ich müss noch trainieren wir hol
noch auf und ja wir spielen den ganzen
Dezember auch noch am 19.11 kommt unsere
Album in Farbe als Reedition raus und
erstmalig mit einer Live DVD drauf wir
haben es der happy nachgemacht und haben
in der Großen Freiheit in Hamburg ein
Konzert mitgefilmt und das kommt jetzt
eendlich raus wir sind sehr stolz auf
tourdoko dabei also das fette fetteste
Paket was wir eigentlich jemals auf man
kann nicht sagen Vinyl ne auf CD auf den
Silberling gepr was ist das
Silikon auf Kunststoff gepresst haben
das kommt raus 1911 ist es soweit und da
freuen wir uns natürlich drauf super
dann damit viel Erfolg und noch eine
super Tour hab einen guten Tourbus weil
wir letztlich waren wir bei Patrice im
Tourbus und der war sensationell mit
Bodenmosaik und sensationell l
undsch das ist er ist halt so Patrice
ist eh schon sie luxuriösere Ecke sind
die dreckigen stinkend den Rockmusiker
überall klebt Bier auf den Gängen jetzt
ist nämlich doch das Klischee weißt du
wir müssen uns ja auch irgendwie
einordnen das tun wir d mit unserem
turourbus genau das ist ja auch immer so
die Leute weren sich immer gegen
Klischees aber eigentlich wollen sie
erfüllen gut vielen Dank danke schön
danke